this is the epic voice of honest
trilogies john bailey and this is the
creator of honest trailers and host of
the levites
and he's ignore should we share our
reviews of some movies out right now
yeah sure man sounds great
what did you think of Jurassic world
most fun I've had since I was 2 even
though the story didn't make any sense
I was she running around in heels yeah
really Mad Max fury road that was fun to
look at but what the hell was the movie
ant-man the tiny film for Marvel which
is pretty much the same thing as Iron
Man with a guy in a suit who shrinks
down does it I look forward to less
origin story Avengers 2 basically
Avengers 1 but not as good Magic Mike
XXL full of abs and horny housewives
there was more stripping this time I'll
strip off like you wanted tattoo in the
live-action Family Guy movie exactly
like the first time wasn't funny it
wasn't it wasn't as bad as a million way
to die in the West I always do like a
big musical number that's expensive and
doesn't have a single joke it's likes
musicals so glad it didn't do well sorry
ex machina is creepy I loved it it was
the technology version of gone girl very
similar to Black Mirror guys are
watching on Netflix check out that great
show o terminator never again asss yeah
they're existing outside of time now
what I will say I kind of like the
beginning I didn't think I'd like old
Arnie like old Arnie sold me that moats
more I learned the moment where you
saves the picture after they've gone
through time and you realize does he
care that was amazing and I wish that
had been the movie but man the whole
relationship I wanted to vomit San
Andreas no comment
he loved the rock yes we to piranhas
trailers this series ever made
you're still happening keeping them
honest one movie trailer at a time
[Music]